what happened to
you nothing I was attacked by
someone long story short not someone I
knew very well but I guess someone who
at the moment I
thought was Jer to me anyway and um
where did this happen oh this was in the
valley I was in the valley with some
friends we went out and then I kind of
walked off for a bit with a sky and
anyway so
uh so like I went and got myself taking
care and then I went to stay at like
just this place for a bit just like for
like a a week or two just to just to
clear my
head kind of like
a like a battered kind of anyway it's
fine I got a feeling you're not telling
me something I mean it's nothing major
it's fine this thing happens to tons of
people I can always tell by your body
weight what you've been where you've
been yeah and I can tell you've not been
on the
street yeah when I'm on the street I'm a
lot more
animated and you're a lot thinner too
yeah do I look fat no you're just thick
I got fat Mark I gained weight I have a
bell dep you ask I was eating a lot
you've gained weight yeah it's the best
thing
about breakups and bastards is you can
eat your way through it and no one will
ever say a
thing I was worried about you a lot of
people were worried about you yeah it's
it's actually really strange to me cuz
it only just registered to me to to
actually check on like replies or
comments or any of that and I realized
like thank you so much to everyone out
there I want to say I had no idea that
so many people knew who I was Al we've
built a huge following now it's it's
interesting yeah I on my on the bus on
my way from the valley to here literally
this morning the second I got on the guy
just goes soft my underbelly and I'm
like oh yeah hi and he's like hi Rebecca
and I'm like hi it was just a random bus
he was so sweet he was like like going
out of his way to just be polite people
love you yeah you tried to give me money
it was weird I was like stop you're
embarrassing yourself he so
sweet did everything sort of walk me off
the bus you know what I mean like escort
me off yeah people are just it's weird
but I don't cuz I don't know how to
interact with cuz I suppose the sort of
the channels of where of how I socialize
mean I don't get to meet people so I
don't get to meet these people and I
know a lot of a lot of you guys are
probably La based cuz at least from when
I read in the comments so it's weird to
have following here in La cuz I
love this city so like shout out to you
guys thank you I don't even want to say
fans cuz it sounds like very overrated
to say but thanks for noticing me
they're just people who love you I I
love I I I can't even begin to equate
that that doesn't make sense to me to
get love from strangers that I've never
met like I thought I'd have to meet them
but it's just it's it was that's kind of
why like I was saying earlier like
that's why I came out of I don't want to
say hiding but that's what encouraged me
is I was just
like yeah can I ask you to show us your
whole face oh um do you want to take the
scarf off yeah or or just just pull it
aside there you go I still look like
Rosemary
detet more like Rosemary DEET you great
I don't look pretty I am bearded and the
lipstick on your eyes I'm not sure about
but everything oh no I was thinking cuz
when I was thinking this I don't know if
anyone would know this but just just
from anyone out there who's been paying
attention to me I just want to show off
my credit here I was thinking of RF
Simmons I was thinking of Dior at first
when I was draping this and then so with
there was a birds of paradise makeup
collection they did once where they
anyway but then I was thinking of the
Chanel show that just happened here not
too long ago at the Paramount Theater
cuz I was like around that area at the
time and I was thinking of how Luchia
Pik up when um anyway you won't get this
but I'm just for the sake of the
interview when she first um went to
Chanel is their new makeup artist their
first female makeup artist her big trick
was her big like kind of which didn't
take off but I was like wasn't surprised
was to do red
like matted um ey Shadow but it was like
glossed on and it was so aggressive cuz
it's very rare that a woman can portray
herself as transgressive and not be
labeled so so to have someone try and
normalize a transgressive woman not an
aggressive woman but a woman who is
aware
of her own like you said maybe weight I
don't know it's one thing with with
difference between and women is weight
is such a strong topic among women and
yet it's men who when faced with it
either completely give up or pursue it
to such an obsessive extent like I've
never heard of a woman doing what
Christian Bale did except for Beyonce
when she drank the cayenne lemon pepper
water but that was more for her voice or
like discipline but like Matthew mccon
Jared lto uh those are pretty extreme
examples Christian B yeah but you know
what I mean takes a lot of discipline
I wouldn't say discipline I I say it's
more ego what what's discipline you know
what I mean I mean those are those are
incredible roles everyone in La is a
Transcendental
Meditation oh sorry a yogi I mean I like
David Lynch but I don't I don't know
feel like TM would kind of limit him a
um here there you use
that but anyway yeah so then I was
thinking I found the scarf and it looked
like Ms and the bag that I found looked
a bit like Ms which makes sense cuz
there's a lot of Ms running around now
that Jane Burkin died cuz she basically
made Ms like Ms would be nowhere without
the Birkin back everyone knows what a
Birkin is no one knows who Jane Birkin
is which doesn't surprise me like it's
it's a very P thing to say but she just
died recently and I used to love her
when I was younger how do you say so
tuned into to what's happening with the
with oh this fashion music I'm not
really as tuned in I mean I would have
been at the Versace show I would have
been at SCH I mean I was around the area
when Chanel happened and I saw some
people coming out and like I watched the
show like I live streamed it with my
friend on the phone from outside the
venue but like we tried to sneak in we
tried our hardest to sneak in how' you
get a phone huh how'd you get a phone oh
A friend gave it to me really a friend
at the at the place there Vinnie shout
out Vinnie thank you Vinnie for the
phone thank you Vinnie thank you Vinnie
Vinnie is a trans man I've never been in
such close confines where it's just one
trans man and one trans woman and
everyone else is like like straight
basically and it was it was really it
was guys and girls but it was like Ed
house you know I mean where everyone had
been through that and the valley is like
the perfect kind of place where you
could find somewhere like that you know
what I mean cuz of all I don't want to
say porn and all that but it's just it's
the valley which like I've always wanted
to go to the valley and like spend time
there you know what I mean like I didn't
really get to to be
honest but like from what I saw it like
aside from that attack like it was very
I don't want to say share horror WIS
but it was very wed out hor what
happened to you oh no nothing nothing
just some dude tried it with me but then
he got violent was the issue and that's
why and then I had to like literally the
cops came and had to take me to the
hospital cuz it was
rough I'm just happy you got
arrested it's weird cuz like I don't
want to say I kind of liked him but you
know it's always that one guy
that one kind
of like it's like honestly I used to
love that movie Jennifer's Body growing
up so it's kind of like that you know
what I mean well anybody who would have
a hard time with somebody like yourself
I would think is somebody know it's just
he wanted more than I wanted to get him
I just didn't want to blow him basically
and he was like well you're going to do
it anyway and then he he like pinned me
down and this was in public and then
starts like but it but it's but it's a
person who is really uncomfortable with
their attraction for I don't think it
was about that I mean he wasn't like
some straight guy no no no he was just
like that was the irritating part was he
seemed like a good guy
like I don't know it's problem like I
don't say mixed race people but there's
a lot of people in La who have like this
like mixup of culture where it's like
machismo and not especially like in the
latinx community there's a lot of Latino
men cuz he was like part Latino it was
like Latino and his mom was white or
something so it was like the dad was cuz
someone was telling me too that his dad
beat him that's that that was kind of
why I felt bad for him at first and like
that's kind of why like like I literally
like let him put his head on my shoulder
we were like at a concert or something
anyway but then like it was like a
really cute endearing moment
honestly I've seen a lot of tough Macho
guys who are on the down low oh no he's
not down low he's just just a
schizophrenic he's just he's
just a man who he's just a man you know
Shamir said it best Shamir is a singer
songwriter I love and there a song it's
a really like poppy nice song but
sometimes a man ain't what he says he is
sometimes a man is just a
man you know think of gong girl you
know big reason why I came to La was
gong girl that's what inspired me
to I don't know it helped me idealize in
myself like I don't want to say strength
cuz that seems like an like an a Very
meta thing to say in this instance is to
go straight to strength rather than
speak of pain or whatever it's not that
it's not like physical or emotional pain
it's
just the the intensity sometimes of an
encounter and
exchange like I never thought I'd ever
ever feel that way you know I feel like
you almost like I don't want to say
encourag that but like try to cuz in the
states people are more I don't want to
say just emotionally tuned but it's okay
to go to
a I'm curious cuz I saw something
outside I saw the um the wrestler right
he had an
mm which reminds me of MTO Mory why did
you name your channel soft my
underbody I'm not sure it just it's an
interesting title you I could come up
with some heavy meaning behind it but
it's just you know bums spelled when you
acronym it soft white underbelly it's
bums
spelled um the other way around Buu Ms
belly under white soft well then I don't
I don't want to give it some heavy
meaning behind it it's just a stupid
title you had to had to name it
something what ironic you moved it
here I had a good time with you the last
time we got together huh back in
September mid yeah I'm sorry if I was
rude or weird when we went to Grand
Central Terminal you were just
no no no but I was we got kicked out of
that restaurant oh they wouldn't let us
in Mark they we they let us sit down
they wouldn't let us in they wouldn't
seat us the host asked us to leave yeah
the host asked us to leave and we were
standing outside which I'm not surprised
by I think I don't think it's just I
think it's sometimes
like that's why I say like doing this
has given
me such a it's just a reputation of
being Troublesome are just what have you
learned about your years on the streets
like this being my worth being
disrespected oh it's not that I'm
disrespected no to be honest with you
this is this is light this is I mean
compared to the other places in the
states I went to even New Orleans
compared to New Orleans this is
it was interest it's interesting here
though because it's very someone was
saying this to me earlier earlier today
actually we were smoking just before I
left we were having cigarette in the
morning and um this girl goes people
here are very passive aggressive I was
like yeah I'm genuinely surprised that
the kombucha Kashmir sweater sat like
the Greg shade I don't know if you know
what the Elder statesan is but it's like
the Elder Statesman gops that are so
passive
aggressive and it's almost unbeknownst
to
them there's two factions of it there's
a part of it that's like a
cult and people in that cult you know
the LA it's other it's either the LA
cult or the Hollywood cult or the kind
of more California shamanic cult who are
very aware of their culture right can't
spell cult without
culture and then there's the people who
aren't aware of it you know what I mean
and there are some people who are cool
because maybe they are people who work
for other people or like maids bus Boys
Food Truck people you know who just have
their own culture and are segregated to
their own environments but then there're
the kind of people who are like social
climbers as they say people trying to
penetrate something intellectually that
they don't understand like they come
here for fame or money you know the kind
of people who are like ooh I want to
sell my soul to the devil and or
alternatively I would never sell my soul
to the devil um you know Praise Jesus or
whatever both of those factions make no
sense to me in in a town that built it's
living off
of essentially God and the devil kind of
agreeing to look the other
way it's like having a Handler versus
having a fixer you know you have a
Handler you're dealt with you have a
fixer you can do what you
want and it doesn't
leak which I'd rather have which one do
you need both you do um schedules a
Handler and someone to definitely yeah
no definitely both which is good
honestly seeing as
I'm you know split either way I always
notice I have two cameras I know I keep
talking about those dreaded Olsen twins
but I always think of that one is Mary
Kate and that one is Ashley what is your
attraction to to the Olson twins um
honestly it's like I said cult earlier
it's a similar sort of Vin like I'm not
as familiar with their their the
they did when they were younger because
I didn't grow up with that like I've
Just Seen I've seen New York minute and
I saw Passport to Paris with my cousin
and there's one in Australia but there's
something about those two girls that
just clicks for you no the RO I mean
mother right so um in in it's very
religious to me because in my craft to
take mother split it into
two and take the ideology of of the
devil and make it the
row when you think of a mother right
because the row is just mother they they
took it and then flip the m to a w
because they're witches and it's I mean
it's it's it's it's known in this town
like they they give out Crystals at
their Chen so people know they're
witches it's not just that they're
witches it's
that they have
this complete sensibility to being a
woman
like there's something just in their
face that you see it's it's completely
it's an
honest like their bag it's called the m
and the way they spelled MGO like you
think Margot Tenon bom or something or
something kind of silly and artsy like
that it's like when they say soft
refinement there's a term in fashion now
which is quiet
luxury and they basically invented that
whole sub niche of just dressing
minimally like they created minimalism
before minimalism was the thing like
everyone says Prada is minimal or rafs
is minimal ra minimal ref does color
they invented
minimalism I doubt no they genuinely no
no no like they they understood what the
Japanese did and gave it a feminine
sensibility it's like what Chanel did
when Chanel put a woman in a suit it
wasn't so much to emasculate her as to
make her equality something to present
in
society and now you can present
intelligence you can present awareness
self-awareness you don't have
to let people know that you're
intelligent you don't have to give away
your secret they don't run around with
pentagrams on their heads but
it's there the energy is there
and when I think of what I would want to
teach my daughter I would teach her the
row like if I were to teach a practice
of
craft not just witchcraft but of craft
cuz craft is such a derogatory term what
what is the row the row so mother CU
there's two of them there's the and then
there's R and Mary Kate usually dresses
in black or darker colors and it
reflects her nature and then Ashley
usually dresses in white cuz she's more
gamine and you can see it in her eyes
like you say the eyes are the windows to
the soul with Mary Kate there's a it's
not just a dryness but it's like when I
say Jean M like I'm obsessed with Jean M
because in her eyes there was like a
wicked kind of but it was like a very
self-aware wickedness versus I'd say
like KRV who her thing is like dear in
headlights like it's either fear or
shock or now Jean would always play the
kind of f fatal but like not an action F
fatal like a woman who knew how to take
advantage of social situations rather
than it's not like Grace Jones and K was
very good at the sensuality of appearing
to be vulnerable or at least least of
that in a woman so it's interesting how
Jean mul aged exactly how you would
imagine just not faded Into Obscurity
but just like I remember I saw an
interview of her once with Michael St
she was she was at s show had men's show
which is weird for her age I think this
was just before she passed and she was
sitting next to Michael stype and Gus
vanand and it was really weird to me oh
shout out to them anyway yeah when you
take order the Eastern Star all you've
got left is the L and the
[Music]
N it's like my Guiding Light I don't
know but let's not let's not reveal the
secrets of the witches of Hollywood
mainly because it's a different kind of
Witchcraft it's witchcraft for the sake
of being a woman rather than the
spectacle of being perceived by a man I
think Practical Magic did a good thing
of softening it charm made it
commercially like like a socialable
thing you have to remember um witchcraft
was the very
first um how do you say Kuda clef as
they say in French sorry
you're you were speaking French earlier
oh your assistants are amazing I'm
surprised they're an older couple I
thought you'd get young assistants I
thought that that young black girl was
you know I was so Curt to her I didn't
mean to be rude last time you weren't
rude oh I hope I wasn't just sometimes
people
genuinely it's all looked down upon me
but like I ran into a girl today
ironically like a trans girl anyway um
in downtown I was I just gotten off the
bus and I was walking around I was
tumbling for a dollar to get to buy a
cigarette and then I see this um trans
girl I was in jail with who was always
really like weird to me like it was like
a weird coddling mother relationship
where she like kept trying to like
coddle me and be my mother but then you
know like like kind of abusive and it
was just
bizarre and I can't I couldn't even
remember her name at first and I was
like oh are you treasure or something
like that and she's like you know
who I am I'm like huh I will uppercut
you and I'm like I don't remember like I
just remember her always making a point
of like she's like oh you're nasty
you're a nasty girl you don't shower and
I'm like I lit just like I used to
shower a lot when I was in there too
she's like oh no you're going in there
to the boys I'm like what is wrong
with you why are you speaking like a
toddler well there's you got to
understand there's severely mentally ill
people downtown it's it's it's not just
severely mentally ill people it's just
you know when when Trump said the
deplorables it's just like a bunch of
people who cuz I know where I come from
I don't want to make that the the uh the
title of this but where I come from you
don't uh glorify your own suffering you
don't glorify your own poverty you don't
force yourself to live in your own filth
for the sake of it it's very backward to
do that I would say in a society and
that's the weird thing with downtown is
I'm surprised the government has allowed
it to remain the way it has because it's
just it's purposefully on
itself you know what I mean like when
you think of like when you go to New
York and you go to Harlem I won't say
Harlem doesn't look like that but in
Harlem it's very they're very proud and
they're very it's not just friendly it's
like they're going out of their way
to to further their culture while
attaining their past like that's a way
to do it self- respectful you know what
I mean like the ER Badu kind of I don't
to say Lil Kim but there's just a
certain subset of you know I mean like
when I think of cardi B like that's a
girl who glorifies how she grew up you
know what I mean like she's proud to be
sort of rat but like the way she
refined
herself like she went from being you
know what I mean just some funny
nothing to like being really intense and
then just went out and had fun with it
it's weird you know what I mean for her
not to be aggressive you know there's
people who when they come into that sort
of money or when they look at money
they'll get really angry and be like why
don't I have this and want to attack
people you know they say Eat the Rich
it's true
like the storming of the bastile
was I mean you already had them in jail
it was just the craziest
thing let them eat cake there's so much
free cake down there mark there is they
give away so much free cake the Midnight
Mission back to the mm thing sorry I'm
very superstitious but when it comes to
a mental Mor especially because today is
February the 8th and I was sorry
December the 8th I was trying to tell
the driver earlier that today is very
important cosmically cuz at least in my
vein of mysticism my ve witchcraft it's
the day at the end of the year where you
culminate everything that you've
received so I was trying to explain to
him how through your morning your
activities I mean it's it's whether
you're basically light or dark but your
activities will either accumulate
everything that you've done so that by
night you'll reap what you've sewn or
the other way around to me surprisingly
it's gone it's going from light to dark
tonight
so anyway sorry I hope not boring you no
I'm just glad you're okay of course I'm
always going to be okay I was I was
worried about
you maybe you got deported maybe you're
in jail maybe you got I I didn't go to
jail thank
God thank God no nothing has changed on
that front since then they they were
trying to help me there God bless them
but like they just didn't have the
resources that's kind of why I decided
to come back out and just like I have to
go face that so I either have to March
down to City Hall and find out a way or
I don't know I need to get a lawyer cuz
I'm worried about like it's not warrants
it's just like I don't want to have to
be
detained cuz ice centers are insane and
I couldn't go without a cigarette if I
can avoid it and I read online that I
could avoid it you know what I mean
having to do jail time like I heard that
you can clear misdemeanors like La I can
just literally go clear them for you and
then the thing the jails are pretty
packed well there's nothing that you're
doing that really needs to it's just
peanut butter like peanut butter
sandwiches it's just like you're eating
and slop all day it's like you
literally eating and vomit you
you've been in jail before yeah I went
to jail I told you I went to jail how
many times I've been taken into like
like where they keep you overnight like
County oh I've been in county jail once
I told you when I that's when I remember
when I went in for the inducement
exposure and then I went to that program
thing and then I a all that was last
year that was the only time I've been in
like Jail jail it's just like Paris you
know what I mean literally 28 days
28 days
salute a lot of people are so worried
that you you've disappeared I read
online that there was literally a a
Reddit or something like I found a
Reddit where people there was like a
conspiracy theory that I died or
something and I I feel like I don't know
Celebrity Skin well there was a a video
that someone showed me on uh I think on
Tik Tok of somebody that looked exactly
like you oh yeah I saw that dude that's
a kid that I used to like not believe
but he was like this kid he was totally
naked getting beaten up down in a skid R
oh no that wasn't me no that couldn't be
that hasn't happened there no they're
actually really sweet to me Mark like
all the people especially outside sassy
today they're like going out of their
way like giving me cigarettes and like
do you any money do you this they know
that all they were so sweet to me yeah I
know yeah you're you're you're you're
very loved on I want you to give me
something so I can compensate them when
I got back please like a little extra so
I can pass it around or something cuz
those kids were so weird to me like I
didn't realize people there valued me I
thought they just thought I was just
like some weird white boy bum
trying to just you know like I I didn't
realize that there was a genuine
awareness of who I was there I didn't
realize like I was
I haven't been humanized in a while if
that makes sense it's a personal thing H
oh o I thought I had my water
there but honestly grace these ches are
so
tight don't do that I thinking of
Jennifer's Body you ever seen that movie
Jennifer's Body never Megan Fox Burns
her tongue and goes I am a
god makes me think of panie I love panie
so what are you going to do now with
your life any plans um continueing my
craft I'm going to try and get an
Instagram done and going try and Link it
to this because um there have been
people in the comments who genuinely
want to work with me people who work in
the industry too I don't know if they're
serious about it or not but like I know
I've read a lot of comments from like
people who are stylist or whatever who
are like I'd love to give her an
opportunity yeah I've had people I've
had a stylist contact me saying she'd
like to hire you as an assistant I would
love to except yeah Mark it's fine I
won't do drug like whatever no no no no
I would love to do that for you but I
don't think you're reliable I think I
can do that Mark if you can just
facilitate that for me please with with
all due respect after what I've just
been through come come see me tomorrow
I'll be downtown tomorrow all right okay
and I will hunt down her email and I'll
try to put you guys pick up my two
phones and I'll get your phone one for
my K and one for Ashley well no one for
today and another one for tomorrow oh
I'm getting one today oh right we're
going today right yeah you're going to
lose you're going to lose the phone
that's why I get more than one well I
have a backup one with me today so you
do yeah I do so you hold on to other
people's phones I lose my purses and I
lose my phones and I lose my perception
maybe you're growing up becoming more
responsible which perhan do you prefer
the one in the Matrix or the Hercules
one I prefer the one in the Matrix I
love Monica beluchi I don't get the
Hercules one I
know like why do the devil so wrong
Hades is not the devil the underworld is
like it's a very confusing thing like
the Devil is a very severe thing to me
it's like it's like Beyond religion like
in at least in my anyway you know it's
just lived the lived
backwards I'm sorry the lived devil is
just lived so it's just so it's like
some Dead Guy basically oh devil and the
word devil is just lived the other way
around so you've died and then anyway uh
let me not get too philosophical here
yes I mean I love him could you imagine
like having to not
only be an insant of all pain and
suffering but to people don't think
about it he does have to suffer himself
here's what I think you should
do but it's like when they say Sympathy
for the Devil you know what I mean
there's some bad bad people out there
who've done some really good things
here's what I think you should do you
should hang on to a phone all right Mark
and start a YouTube channel okay and tie
into somebody's bank account you can do
it with you know you can do it with me
and I'll give you all the money you're
sweet and uh just share your thoughts
and experiences and I was thinking of
maybe getting it real done honestly I'd
love to do a screen test even for just
like some dumb Indie slasher movie I'm
sure I'd have some kind of appeal I mean
hunter Schaefer is in the new games and
Hunter Schaefer had her whole
come up on doing drugs and getting paid
on HBO to make zunda look
more ethnically
diverse let me get a closeup sorry
people forget Zena once came out with a
song sponsored by Vivian Westwood called
closeup directed by
ranen all right Mr de I'm ready for my
closeup can't believe they went with
zund over bellthorn love born
Lauren hardcore
hardcore like the brook County of
Disney she like the brook County
of drag I don't
know you ever get a chance to see movies
or or look at who Lou exactly do you
ever get a chance to see movies now oh
movies no but I've seen trailers and
from what I've seen I just haven't found
anything appealing I was watching a lot
of like trash TV reality TV I started
trying to watch un just like thought but
that was just misery and it made me want
to watch the old sex in the cities and
then I ended up just binging all
the bling Empires on Netflix like bling
Empire bling Empire New York and Dubai
bling over and over you have a Netflix
account no they had Netflix where I was
it's fine it's just Netflix it's like
cheap as but then I had like an app
on my phone where I could just watch
anything for free and I just ended up
watching a ton of like you know like
family guia Simpsons all that just like
real American I went back to watch Daria
oh and then I watched The Virgin
Suicides again but that's just like I'll
do that once a year anyway that's
literally like
it's like going to mecca for
me that was the movie that really if I
want to talk about the movie that made
me a girl or a woman and it sounds
really really
really pathetic to say cuz just to my at
least to my generation but The Virgin
Suicides that was it like we're talking
about Mary Kate and Ashley or the RO or
whatever The Virgin Suicides kind
of gave their ow its
wings
you know it's six women
[Music]
and seven
men I'm just glad you're
okay
yeah I could have been Lux lb I could
have been
Cecilia I know Mommy
Dearest you want to shave I definitely
want to shave take a shower maybe yeah
that might be nice okay all right thanks
Rebecca guys watch take check out for
take two or whatever and I watch a bunch
of YouTubers and they're always
like